[Musique]
tout près de paris à vos pieds
promeneurs cette rosace délicate c'est
le jeune pissenlit et cette perle à son
centre c'est la future flers colette
s'est un peu trompé la fleur du
pissenlit est en réalité un ensemble de
fleurs toutes semblables sept autres
plantes que nous mangeons en boutons
l'artichaut ses bractées les feuilles
d'artichaut enferme les futurs fleurs de
l'artichaut le foin nous retrouvons les
mêmes parties dans un pissenlit en
boutons ce bouton fait de nombreuses
fleurs devient la chandelle du pissenlit
fait de nombreuses graines
tout comme les fleurs de l'artichaut été
portée par un réceptacle comestibles le
choeur les graines du pissenlit
maintenant mur tombe de la tête de moine
le réceptacle du pissenlit devenant
chauffe
mais la partie délicieuse du pissenlit
n'est pas sa fleur mais sa feuille
manger en salade
n'attendez pas que le printemps soit
trop avancé n'attendez pas que les
pissenlits forme des champs de fleurs et
puis essayer de faire votre cueillette
loin des pollutions
il vaut mieux demander l'autorisation
aux propriétaires vous trouverez les
pousse les plus tendres dans les
taupinières où elle pousse à l'abri
[Musique]
frédéric legrand en faisait à table une
consommation quotidienne
le souverain assuré qu'il devait à cette
cure de pissenlit sa complexion
vigoureuse son teint frais et son humeur
joyeuse le pissenlit et tonique
dépuratif est comme son nom l'indiqué
diurétique
on dit que pour prévenir la cirrhose
pour éviter de manger les pissenlits par
la racine
il est recommandé de boire cette
infusion
[Musique]
cette racine se cueille en août et
septembre
[Musique]
racine qui contient du latex et dont on
essaie chez certaines espèces de tirer
du caoutchouc torréfié les broyer on
peut la confondre avec la chicorée
racines très prisé des dames de la
renaissance
elle se laver le visage à l'eau de
pissenlit pour faire disparaître les
taches de rousseur les points noirs les
boutons et même les taches de vieillesse
[Musique]
voici enfin un procédé pratique et sûr
pour connaître la date de votre futur
mariage
autant de fois vous soufflerait autant
d'années vous attendrez si la graine
tombe c'est mauvais signe
si elles s'envolent ce sera le bonheur
[Musique]